bonjour lucien muller conseil
départemental du canton de wintzenheim
j'ai souhaité sert cette petite
interview pour présenter le travail du
département
un peu dans la nature puisque je dis
toujours que c'est un travail de
proximité et pour moi c'est la
définition même du conseiller
départemental en effet que ce soit au
niveau de l'environnement comme au
niveau du social je reviendrai un peu
plus tard dans la compétence
départementale
nous devons être toujours proche des
autres est également proche des élus
pour les aider à définir leurs projets
leurs besoins et éventuellement monter
leur dossier
alors dans ce travail je suis accompagné
de monique martin où vous avez également
pu voir son interview et nous nous
partageons partiellement ce canton mais
sur les projets importants nous
travaillons vraiment en binôme main dans
la main ce canton il a une économie très
diversifiée entre l'industrie
l'agriculture de montagne
la vigne le vin et le secteur
touristique dont un des symboles et le
veilleur de nuit de turckheim nos
dossiers nous les défendons à travers
les contrats de territoire de vie
initiée par le conseil départemental du
haut rhin et surtout à travers notre
compétence obligatoire est la plus
importante qui ait le social j'ai pour
habitude de dire que nous accompagnons
nos concitoyens de leur naissance
jusqu'à la fin de vie par des exemples
c'est ici la rénovation et l'extension
de la maison dans abidjan